you're saying that right up front so
you're not even trying to
uh do the impossible you're just making
sure you have certain set of criterias
that you get the best result you focus
on those folks yeah you know the fact is
it looks like what we're doing sometimes
looks
miraculous and of course it's not at all
because all we're doing is getting the
body to do what it does best and that's
heal itself when you get out of the way
we actually don't do anything when you
think about it other than carefully
select and monitor patients to go
through this very natural process
and what's interesting and what i've
learned in response to your question
is that the people that respond the best
of fasting
are the patients that have problems that
were brought about
by dietary excess so you know when you
think about it it's not shocking that
conditions like obesity
and cardiovascular disease including
high blood pressure type 2 diabetes
autoimmune diseases and conditions like
lymphoma these conditions we know from
experience
are made worse by poor dietary choices
it's not shocking that they would get
well faster with fasting than they would
perhaps in other circumstances because
the reason they're sick to begin with
is because they haven't taken the
ability to control what they're putting
in their mouth and they're developing
diseases of dietary excess these
diseases used to be called the diseases
of kings
because it was the wealthy elite kings
that used to get these
conditions now they've become ubiquitous
because even
poor people in our modern uh
world are living as only kings used to
live in the past that is eating
highly concentrated highly refined foods
what do you mean by these diseases are
named after kings can you name it for
example cardiovascular disease and high
blood pressure used to be very rare the
only people that used to develop
cardiovascular disease coronary artery
disease
were the wealthy elite they could afford
to eat like
we all eat today uh you know in in in
the
world of our ancient ancestors getting
enough to eat not getting eaten was the
imperative of life in fact most humans
according to anthropologists never lived
to reproduce
they never passed on their genes it was
only the rare
people that survived long enough to pass
on those jeans and those were our
ancestors
the people that didn't make it were you
know what we call losers they didn't
they're not your ancestors your
ancestors are the winners
we're the end result of a thousand
generations of successful survival and
reproduction
we're the the peace to resist don'ts and
the problem is our brains that allowed
us to do that
were uh designed evolved in the
environment of scarcity
and now we've changed the environment
because humans are so innovative and so
creative we've been able to change our
environment
and now we live in an environment of
abundance and as a consequence of those
changes our brain doesn't serve us well
unless we become very conscious
of the vulnerability to the pleasure
trap
that's very deep so now you're saying 90
is uh
you you pretty much lock on to the
people that are the ideal candidates for
you to work on
not the impossible cases what is an
ideal candidate to go on a potential
10 20 30 even a 40 day fast so i find
what uh
appropriately motivated patients have
better long-term success
and the most effective motivation in my
experience
are pain debility and fear of death so
we tend to see a lot of people that are
kind of they call us true north health
center the last resort
because many of the people they've tried
all the pills and potions powders the
surgeries
all the magic bullets all the easy fixes
and now they have to get down and dirty
and do the hard work
and it is really difficult to live
healthy in our society today
because the society is designed to give
you what you want
not necessarily what you need and what
we want is
to live uh without having to limit any
of our behaviors
and what we need is to figure out a way
to escape the dietary pleasure trap and
actually give the body a chance to heal
itself
how do you do that uh what we do is
education so we teach people about
the fact that health results from
healthful living and from our viewpoint
healthful living involves diet sleep and
exercise
so we teach people how to make sure they
prioritize their sleep
do they get appropriate activity and
that they control what they put in their
mouth
and from our viewpoint that diet is a
whole plant food diet that's sos free
and as you know sos is the international
symbol of danger
it also stands for chemicals that we add
to food that fool the satiety mechanisms
in our brain
lead to systematic overeating and lead
to the metabolic syndrome that's in
epidemic today and that metabolic
syndrome is responsible for contributing
to the diabetes the high blood pressure
the autoimmune disease and some forms of
cancer so when people are educated about
that they can make a decision to make
you know make sure they're sleeping
exercising eating properly some people
that's not enough they need a little
extra help
and that's where we have an inpatient
facility where people can come in
and and live in a controlled setting so
that they can
go through fasting if necessary safely
they can make the dietary changes
and they can get educated about what
it's going to take to actually get well
and once people experience getting well
sometimes they're motivated
to comply what does o stand for in sos
oil so it's salt oil and sugar those are
the chemicals that we put in the food
that make us fat sick and miserable
so those are the worst salts oil and
sugar
yeah so these are not actually food but
there are
fractionated food byproducts that we put
into the food to stimulate the dopamine
in our brain